le temps presse tu as vu ce qui se passe
là bas
on tente une approche par derrière
rebonds
pour toi
thomas est gérable il finira bien par
débarquer tout seul
c'est précisément ce qui m'inquiète
ils nous ont capturé parce que vous êtes
immunisés immunisé contre un fléau qui
anéantit l'espèce humaine
mais non ils sont prêt à vous sacrifier
pour trouver le remède ne s'arrêteront
jamais c'est à nous de les stopper la
dernière ville le quartier général de
wickham la tanière du lion mais armada
et c'est là où on va on a passé trois
ans derrière des murs a essayé de
s'évader et maintenant il faut y
retourner
je monte devant
le monde est en train de mourir
mais si nous trouvons un vaccin nous
n'aurons pas fait tout ça pour rien
sur great de nous avoir trahi
je vais fait pour notre bien on entre
mais je sais pas si on pourra revenir
on a commencé ensemble on finira
ensemble
[Musique]
tu tiens toujours à sève c'est ça tu
vois la vérité approche
combien de gamins vont-ils encore
enlever torturer tuer quand s'arrête le
cauchemar s'arrêtera quand on aura
trouvé un remède
comment tu peux choisir de sauver ses
amis
ou de tous nous sauver
s'il te plaît tommy je tends vrai